okay so we're on the final question
we've done a through F podgy says sketch
roughly because we don't have any like
equation here so I can only do it
approximately at different points sketch
roughly the graphs of velocity and
accelerations so what I've got down here
I have something I prepared earlier is
I've got some axes already drawn and you
can see they're vertically sort of in
line underneath my displacement graph
and that reason I'm gonna do that is
because I'm gonna use this displacement
graph and I'll show you I encourage you
to do it exactly like this to draw and
identify the features on my floss in in
my acceleration graphs as well so let's
start by looking at this displacement
graph and if I'm trying to do velocity
here I'm the easiest points to graph are
the stationary points the reason why is
because let's choose an appropriate
color here let's go further let's come
back to red these stationary points here
they represent a velocity of 0 take it
back
red is a terrible choice because I used
it for my um actually down below let's
go to dark green ok so you can see here
these spots are these times time three
and time nine because you're stationary
your velocity is zero so if I come down
to and this is actually not a
displacement graph it's a velocity graph
I should have at time three and time
nine I should have a velocity of zero
like so all right now earlier on we were
noticing when we have a look at the
gradient here you've got let's go to the
right green this is a you know
increasing part of the graph it's
positive gradient and then this is also
a positive gradient right so what that
means is down here on my velocity graph
I'm going to have a section over here
where the velocity graph needs to be
positive right let's make that color
match because it's bothering me
there we go okay so to the left of time
three or before time three because I
have an increasing graph the velocity
has to be positive and then I also have
to have the same thing after time no
right because again the graph up here is
positive now conversely if you have
look at this in between section here
this is negative right so I should say
the gradient is negative it's a
decreasing function in this little part
of the domain so what that corresponds
to is the fact that let's just pinch
this rectangle over here what that
corresponds to is I'll make it like so
you're going to have this section here
where I'm so dizzy where you've got a
negative gradient so your velocity must
be beneath zero so that's why it's
negative and you can see I had to add
that to my velocity axis I've got this
negative value over here okay so my
velocity graph is going to pass through
the shaded regions here and you can see
this is starting to have a familiar sort
of shape right this is going to be a
parabola of some kind now before I
finish and just sort of like draw a
parabola all the way through and just
say oh I reckon it would be roughly that
right I know it's gonna be in that
vicinity I actually do have enough
information on the graph to provide a
little more detail doesn't have to be
precise if you have a look over here
right um you can very roughly guess at
some of the gradients that you're going
to get okay um if for example you
remember me putting in some of these
time markings right if you have a look
at say time one okay
coincidentally maybe it's not
coincidence maybe they exactly designed
this for this reason you can see if I
read up from time one up to the graph
you can see I hit a displacement of four
okay now the reason why I've picked out
time one is because if you go over one
unit horizontally and that means you go
up four units vertically what this is
telling you is rise over run yeah and
that's gradient which is my velocity
function okay so if my rise over run is
four divided by one then my velocity
should be roughly anyway four so what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to put a
marker again roughly here I'm going to
say okay is there any other information
that I can put on here that helps me and
there is if you come over here for
example in the middle here at time five
again if I draw a line vertically
upwards you can see that's roughly going
over to here so I don't know that's
that's around that's that's around five
and six I think it's slightly closer to
six then to five
so you can see for this downward section
here again I've got a run of one unit
you go four five over to six but you
have a rise of negative two because I I
dropped downwards you can see from six
down to four so if I've got a rise of
negative two over a run of one that
means that my gradient should be roughly
negative two which I would put here so
that spots around my point of inflection
which identified earlier so that's gonna
be around times six okay so I think this
is roughly enough information you can
see because I was predicting a parabola
should be symmetrical so I'm gonna do my
best to try and thread the needle
through here like so I generally find it
easy with parabolas to actually draw
that you have separately and I'm pretty
comfortable with that that parabola
looks like it matches you if the
derivative of what you would expect this
guy which looks roughly like a cubic to
look like so this would have a power of
three it's now a power of two so I'm
pretty comfortable with that so there's
my rough velocity graph and last thing
going to come down and I'm gonna do not
an X displacement I'm gonna do an
acceleration graph now so I read an
acceleration graph from my velocity
graph I'm kind of gonna do this same
process looking for the geometric
features through calculus looking for
these geometric features off of the
velocity and then map them onto the
acceleration you can see I've gotten rid
of my vertical scale here now because I
know that this guy here is approximate
so I'm going to be getting an
approximation actually I think what
we're done here
rub off this by accident I'm going to
getting an approximation of an
approximation for this graph so I know
I'm not gonna have any like numerical
precision here but I can't identify
important points for example this guy
right here a stationary point on the
velocity is going to be a value of zero
for the acceleration right so we
identified this earlier on I think it
was what part of it I kind of remembered
asked so long ago this was Part D right
the acceleration is zero after six
seconds so I can just take that fact and
I can put it onto
Graff here don't know how that
displacement snuck in again and I know
as well if I come back to my graph up
here this this coloring here was looking
at velocity because looking at gradient
but if I think back to concavity which
is what helps me work out an
acceleration equation you can see here
there's that if you remember that
concave up section over here and then
you have the concave down section over
here I can't remember what colors I used
but hopefully that's roughly accurate so
concave down means I'm going to have
negative acceleration concave up means
I'm going to have positive acceleration
so therefore I have to cross over from
switch over here from negative all the
way up to positive and because you know
I had a um a cubic roughly here that
gave me a parabola roughly here and it
gives me a straight line roughly here
and I don't need much more precision
than that because they don't have enough
numerical accuracy to do so so take a
breath it's a big long question there's
a lot to it and part of it was it took a
long time because I was explaining and
talking through those different pieces
so it wouldn't take you this long if you
just doing the question and obviously
you will become more familiar with
interpreting a lot of this language I'm
kind of instinctively as you as you
spend more time practicing and
consolidating those skills when you
think of like acceleration hopefully
your mind immediately goes second
derivative and that will become second
nature so hopefully that was helpful to
you